congratulations on the wedding of the
century it looks so dreamy in the photos
how does it feel to say husband and wife
oh my gosh I you know for the first few
weeks I kept flipping and saying fiance
cuz I said that first along but now
we've got it down and it feels so
amazing every day we feel like it's the
honeymoon and we just got back from our
honeymoon we were down in the Amazon
rainforest and Ecuador so day to day
life as husband and wife has anything
changed what's been the biggest change
maybe she makes me serve her breakfast
in the nude every morning now like
before was just a special occasion
I don't think you're complaining no no
honestly we've been together almost
eight years so we knew each other that
we love each other since when we met and
so our same routines happening where we
filmed we're on a plane every two days
we're filming in Calgary next in Vegas
so a lot of time on the road but just
spending those little moments together
is all I mean we have fun doing nothing
together
yeah I know you build homes for a living
are you thinking about building a family
we are pregnant no I'm just joking oh
you thought you had the news to tell you
no yeah wins me well we actually would
love to have twins yeah
yeah where we will have kids no spring
rush two of her sisters have kids so we
already have five nieces and nephews to
play with yeah yeah no but we will
eventually you'll be the first to know
[Music]